[Music]
at the beginning and the end of my
introductory courses on constitutional
law I asked my students to consider
whether constitutional law is law in the
sense we usually use the word or whether
it's just politics by another name
I also tell them that I don't think this
question has an easy answer
I don't like to tell them how I think
they should think on this question or
any question for that matter but as with
many constitutional questions I
encourage them to recognize that there
are powerful arguments on each side of
the Ledger
my own view is the Constitutional law is
both law and politics
it's law in the sense that the sources
that usually guide U.S legal decision
making text structure precedent history
common law reasoning do guide
constitutional law
most judges including Supreme Court
Justices and constitutional cases
earnestly tried to apply the law
correctly to reach the right legal
answer
some critics accuse the justices of just
assigning cases based on their own
political preferences but I think this
is an oversimplification
most judges take their judicial role
very seriously and feel it is improper
to supplant the law with their own
wishes
where there is clear binding
constitutional precedent that is on
point for the case at hand judges will
usually follow that precedent just as
they would in any other area of law
that said constitutional law yields
fewer clear answers than many areas of
law
for one as we've seen in a variety of
contexts many important constitutional
Provisions are written at a broad level
of generality that requires someone to
interpret them that is to fill in their
meaning
it's not immediately self-evident what
many of the Constitution's most
important Provisions actually mean and
how they apply to questions today
of course some Provisions are clear
for example each state gets two U.S
senators
but many of the provisions that arise
often in constitutional litigation do
not have clear meanings
additionally Supreme Court Justices
historically have employed a variety of
interpretive techniques for
understanding the Constitution what
Professor Philip Bobbitt from Columbia
Law School has called modalities of
constitutional interpretation
and there's no clear hierarchy of these
interpretive approaches
should the justices look first to court
precedence
to the original meaning of the
constitutional text to the structure of
the document to the original
understandings of the people who wrote
the document or who ratified a provision
at issue to relevant past practices
through the generations
there's value in each of these
modalities used separately or in tandem
but when there's so many different ways
of approaching a constitutional question
it should not be surprising that there's
often going to be disagreement about
what the right answer is
the variety of interpretive approaches
is part of what makes constitutional law
fascinating and frustrating
it's also likely part of the reason why
judges so often do decide cases in line
with their political preferences
it is precisely because constitutional
cases often lack clear answers that
justices fall back on their policy
preferences
I think they often do this quite
unconsciously it's just human nature
that in the absence of other reliable
guideposts the justices individual
perspectives on such diverse areas as
history language culture faith and yes
politics are going to color the way they
approach a question at hand
some Scholars such as Bill Eskridge of
Yale law school refer to this phenomenon
as the hermeneutical Circle the idea
that one's background Norms necessarily
color the way one interprets each
individual piece of evidence which in
turn colors the way one interprets
everything else
one's approach to each part affects the
way one sees the whole which in turn
affects the way one sees each part
finally recall the idea from earlier
lectures that constitutional law is
about power and where it resides in
American government
where the law doesn't provide clear
guidance on where that power resides
it's hard for people to set aside their
politics when making consequential
decisions
with all this in mind it should perhaps
not be surprising that political science
research demonstrates quite convincingly
that the justices in the Supreme Court
tend to vote in line with the
preferences of the party of the
president who appointed them there are
exceptions but the empirical data are
quite persuasive that Supreme Court
decision making is political in this
sense
Research into the subject called
cultural cognition helps further explain
these findings
Scholars like Dan Kahan also of Yale law
school have demonstrated that people
tend to gravitate to facts and arguments
that reinforce their existing beliefs
the judges may be more sophisticated in
their reasoning than most people they
are not immune from this phenomenon
in difficult cases with powerful
arguments and evidence on each side of
the Ledger they act like other human
beings by tending to accept the
arguments and evidence that conform to
the World Views they already accept
in light of all this it's probably
oversimplified to assume that some
people do that judges are merely
politicians and robes
but it is also surely naive to believe
that judges are wholly immune from
political influences
the truth as is often the case by
somewhere in the middle
the role of politics and constitutional
law is most evident in the confirmation
battles over judicial nominees
particularly nominees to the U.S Supreme
Court or the stakes are the highest
given that judges tend to vote with
their political tribe at least in close
cases about which reasonable people can
differ each president tries to pick
judges whose votes will likely conform
with the president's political beliefs
the Constitution empowers the president
to appoint federal judges including of
course Supreme Court Justices with the
advice and consent of the Senate
this means that to win confirmation a
president's judicial nominee must make
it through the Senate Judiciary
Committee and then receive a majority of
the vote from the full Senate
because article 3 of The Constitution
promises that federal judges may keep
their jobs during good behavior a
successful judicial appointment is
usually a job for life
it is not uncommon for Supreme Court
Justices to stay in the high court for
two or even three decades long after
their appointing president has left the
White House
in this way a president's Supreme Court
appointments arguably constitute a
president's most enduring Legacy
and the opportunity to exert such
influence is a rare one presidents only
get to a point of Justice when there is
a vacancy on the Supreme Court a
situation that is typically brought
about only by a Justice's retirement or
death
given these high stakes it's inevitable
that the confirmation process will be
highly political and it has become more
political in recent years
the politics of the judicial
confirmation process or on full display
in 2016 after the sudden death of
Justice Antonin Scalia
Justice Scalia had been an almost Larger
than Life figure on the Supreme Court
brilliant provocative funny charming and
an outspoken advocate for originalism
and constitutional interpretation and
for some conservative causes
Justice Scalia was also a great writer
whose Lively prose invariably provokes
great debates among law students love
them or hate him Justice Scalia was
anything but boring
at the time of Justice scalia's death
the Supreme Court was ideologically very
closely divided
the way the news media apply the terms
conservative and liberal to the justices
is often oversimplified but if we think
of those terms as useful shorthand it's
fair to say that four justices were
usually but not always reliable
conservative votes Chief Justice John
Roberts and justices Scalia Clarence
Thomas and Samuel Alito
all four were Republican appointees
four justices were usually but not
always reliable liberal votes justices
Ruth Bader Ginsburg Stephen Breyer Sonia
Sotomayor and Elena Kagan all four were
democratic appointees
that left one Justice Justice Anthony
Kennedy a 1980s Ronald Reagan appointee
as the court Swing Vote in many a case
where Kennedy went the court as a whole
usually went
in reality Justice Kennedy often voted
consistently liberal on certain issues
like gay rights and conservative and
others like federalism
but in some cases it wasn't clear Which
Way Kennedy would vote though it was
clear that his vote would decide the
case's outcome
Justice Scalia died early in 2016 the
last year of Barack Obama's presidency
observers realized that if President
Obama a Democrat were to appoint Justice
scalia's successor the balance of the
Court could shift substantially to the
left
a fifth liberal on the court would help
ensure that the Liberals would win most
cases even if they failed to secure
Justice Kennedy's vote
of course it was unclear how long this
majority would last given that other
justices were also advancing in age but
at least in the short term it seemed
like the Supreme Court might have a
majority of liberal justices for the
first time in well over a generation
with a stake so high Republican
politicians signaled immediately that
they would not confirm anyone President
Obama nominated
the Republicans controlled the senate in
2016 so they had the power to reject
anyone President Obama put forward
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
went even further indicating that the
Senate would not even hold hearings or a
vote on any Obama Supreme Court nominee
Senator McConnell's public argument was
that a presidential election was nine
months away so the American people
should decide
everybody knew the real reason though
was that the ideological balance of the
nation's most important Court was at
stake
faced with a senate that was promising
obstructionism President Obama decided
to nominate about the least
controversial candidate imaginable
he selected chief judge Merrick garland
from the U.S court of appeals for the
D.C circuit
even in a crowded field of exemplary
candidates chief judge Garland stood out
highly respected by lawyers all across
the political Spectrum judge Garland had
an impeccable reputation as a brilliant
meticulous hard-working fair-minded
nonpartisan judge
a Harvard Law graduate and a former
Supreme Court Clerk chief judge Garland
also had a sterling resume including
stints in private practice teaching at
Harvard Law School and working at the
Department of Justice where he headed
the team that prosecuted the
perpetrators of the Oklahoma City
bombings in the mid-1990s
he was also the chief judge of the DC
circuit which is sometimes referred to
as the nation's second most important
court because it hears many of the cases
involving federal administrative
agencies
perhaps even more importantly chief
judge Garland was considered such a
fair-minded judge that some Senate
Republicans had indicated a few years
earlier that if President Obama were to
nominate him for a different Supreme
Court opening they would support him
President Obama no doubt selected judge
Garland precisely because he wanted a
consensus candidate that both
Republicans and Democrats could support
in the interest of full disclosure I
should acknowledge here that I had the
Good Fortune of clerking for judge
Garland for a year
like everyone else I was extraordinarily
impressed with his Fierce intelligence
his tireless work ethic and above all
else his sense of fairness I never just
saw him decide a case based on
pre-formed ideology
true to the early promise however Senate
Republicans refused to give chief judge
Garland either a hearing or a vote
these tactics dismayed me as in my view
the Senate was refusing even to consider
a person who could not possibly be
better qualified to sit on the Supreme
Court
but from a political standpoint the
Republicans Gambit made sense
the late Justice Scalia had been a very
reliable conservative vote
even if judge Garland were a perfectly
Centrist judge his appointment would
swing the court away from the right as
it would replace a very conservative
Justice with a moderate one
Democrats cried foul the Republicans
Behavior broke with the long-standing
practice of giving some deference to the
president's Supreme Court nominee
even when the Democrats rejected
President Reagan's nominee judge Robert
borked to the Supreme Court in the 1980s
they still provided a hearing and a vote
in fact their decision to vote no one
judge bork was based substantially on
what he had said during his confirmation
hearings
and the Democrats view fairly or not
judge bork had espoused an aggressively
conservative rigidly ideological
approach to the law
by contrast judge Garland was offered no
such opportunity to share his Judicial
philosophy with the country
some Democrats contended that Senate
Republicans were acting
unconstitutionally
the argument in effect was that the
constitution grants the president the
authority to appoint federal judges and
the Senate was denying the president his
constitutional prerogative
Democrats further contended that
Republicans argument that they should
wait until after the election to choose
the next Justice had no logical stopping
point
Justice Scalia died nearly nine months
before the election should the Senate
refuse to consider judicial nominees for
vacancies occurring a year before a
presidential election two years
Democrats constitutional protestations
mostly fell on death years
Constitution entrust the Senate with
providing advice and consent for the
president's Federal judicial nominees
though the Senate is often more
respectful of the president's selection
than it was to judge Garland the
Constitution effectively delegates the
confirmation process to the Senate
where the law leaves a matter in the
discretion of a political body one
cannot use the courts to try to change
that body's process and decision
if the Democrats were going to get judge
Garland through
they would have to do it using politics
not law
there seemed to be some reason to think
that the Democrats would succeed in
their efforts
at the time the Republican strategy
seemed risky
Hillary Clinton was the Democratic
Party's candidate for president and she
seemed likely to defeat the Republicans
upstart candidate Real Estate Mogul and
reality TV star Donald Trump
for most of their race she was
substantially ahead in the polls
were Clinton to win the presidency there
was no guarantee she would stick with
judge Garland who was then 63 years old
President Clinton might decide to
withdraw judge Garland's nomination and
choose instead in ideological liberal
who would try to steer the court
aggressively to the left and a much
younger person who might stay in the
court longer
furthermore Republicans refusal to Grant
even a hearing to judge Garland seem to
feed into the Democrats campaign message
that the Republicans were obstructionist
and appeared as though it could alienate
key swing voters in the upcoming
election
but the Republicans gamble of course
paid off Donald Trump won the presidency
and with it the chance to select Justice
scalia's replacement
moreover Republicans held on to their
control of the Senate so president Trump
had his pick of conservatives
he ended up selecting judge Neil Gorsuch
from the U.S court of appeals for the
10th circuit
like chief judge Garland judge Gorsuch
enjoyed a sterling reputation as a
highly regarded judge with an impressive
pedigree and legal mind
but there can be no dispute that
President Trump also chose him because
of his reputation as an ideological
conservative
indeed the folks advising president
Trump on this election including the
influential Federalist Society wanted
just that someone who would consistently
Advance their interests and ideologies
at the Supreme Court
and the Senate of course confirmed judge
Gorsuch as the new Justice
as of this taping the country is now
engaged in another confirmation battle
Justice Anthony Kennedy for years the
Supreme Court Swing Vote has announced
his retirement giving president Trump
his second Supreme Court vacancy to fill
in less than two years
president Trump promised to replace
Justice Kennedy with a committed
conservative in the mold of Justice
Gorsuch
the replacement of the Court's swing
Justice with a consistent conservative
would of course shift the court
substantially to the right
unsurprisingly Democrats have vowed to
fight an ideological conservative
nominee but as Republicans control the
Senate Democrats would need to pick off
some Republican votes to defeat the
nominee
notice that politics rather than
principal guides Senators approaches to
these matters
Democrats who had cried foul when the
Republicans insisted on postponing any
hearing on Judge Garland until after the
election argued in summer 2018 that the
Senate should not vote on a new Justice
until after the November midterm
elections
and Republicans who had said that there
shouldn't be a hearing or a vote on
Judge Garland until after the election
now wants to complete the process as
quickly as possible lest they risk
losing their majority in the election
with these confirmation Battle episodes
show rather starkly I think is that
constitutional law and politics are
inextricably light
the justices themselves May usually try
to apply the law neutrally and
impartially
but their own background views matter
sometimes a great deal
understanding this very well presidents
and Senators support the appointment of
justices whom they believe will vote in
ways that tend to support their own
political viewpoints
it's understandable that the public
sometimes gets the misimpression that
what goes on at the court is politics
and nothing else
political disagreements in American
society have been Fierce since the
nation's founding but they have produced
such vitriol and distrust in recent
years that our political system strikes
many people as dysfunctional
Democrats and Republicans often treat
each other as enemies
this atmosphere makes political
compromise extremely challenging
as the nation looks for Solutions a
logical question is whether the
Constitution itself which lays the
ground rules for our political system
deserves some of the blame for these
problems
it has long been heretical to criticize
the Constitution it is in some ways
America's Civic religion
but a blind faith is not a deep one and
any serious study of the Constitution
should consider which parts are working
well and which ones are not
naturally liberals and conservatives
tend to lament different aspects of our
constitutional law
some conservatives want to amend the
Constitution to provide further
protection for religion or to remove Roe
v Wade's protection of abortion
perhaps conservatives most fundamental
laments though involve the scope of the
federal government and the argument that
it has grown far beyond the framer's
original intentions and the fact that
federal spending and debt have gotten
out of control
for their part many liberals might favor
their own constitutional revisions
many of these pertain to voting and the
political process such as outlawing
partisan gerrymandering protecting the
right to vote and limiting corporations
ability to influence elections through
campaign contributions and election year
and Communications
other liberal objections implicate the
structure of government more generally
the makeup of the Senate some point out
is profoundly undemocratic giving each
state two senators regardless of
population size
the result is that California and
Wyoming enjoy equal power in the Senate
even though the population of California
is close to 70 times that of Wyoming
of course Article 5 of The Constitution
stipulates that no state without its
consent shall be deprived of equal
representation in the Senate so it would
be impossible to alter the makeup of the
Senate without scrappling the
constitution in its entirety
but liberals nevertheless point to the
Senate as evidence that the constitution
is far less Democratic than Americans
sometimes like to think it is
liberals and some conservatives have
similar complaints about the
constitutionally mandated electoral
college process for electing the
president
under Article 2 of The Constitution the
president is elected not by national
popular vote but through elections in
each state
each state is given a certain number of
electoral College votes equal to the
size of the Congressional Delegation
from that state
in other words each state gets the same
number of electoral College votes as the
number of its House and Senate members
combined
as critics have observed this system
gives disproportionate weight to states
with low population since they have
Senate membership disproportionate to
their size
whether or not one likes this
Arrangement it's also undemocratic as it
gives people in some states greater vote
and power than people and others
this electoral college system also has
other consequences
for example the vast majority of states
have a winner take all system so that a
candidate who only narrowly wins a
majority in a state still gets all of
that State's Electoral College votes
as a result candidates tend to focus
their campaigning on key States usually
so-called swing states that could
possibly go either way in an election
candidates spend much less time and
fewer resources on states that they are
assured to win or lose
and they have a strong incentive to make
campaign promises designed to sway
voters in those swing States promises
that can have a significant impact on
the policies of the new Administration
another effect of the electoral college
system is that it can result in
candidates winning the presidency
despite having lost the popular election
for example George W Bush in 2000 and
Donald Trump in 2016 both lost the
popular vote but won the presidency
because they won more Electoral College
votes
the partisan Rancor over these outcomes
especially the 2000 election which
culminated in litigation about a recount
in Florida was intense and Lasting
some critics contend that the losing
side would have an easier time accepting
the results of an election that turned
only on the popular vote
attributing to the nation's political
dysfunction should it be changed
as you may know Article 5 of The
Constitution provides two ways of
proposing a constitutional amendment
the first requires a two-thirds vote by
each house of Congress
the second requires two-thirds of state
legislatures to request that Congress
call for a convention which would then
debate and propose Constitutional
Amendments
in either case a proposed Constitutional
Amendment would need to be ratified by
three-quarters of the states
all the amendments to the U.S
Constitution that have been made to date
have gone through the first process
but a movement is now underway to call a
constitutional convention using the
second process with the goals of
limiting the scope of federal power and
requiring a balanced federal budget
while limiting Federal power and
requiring a balanced budget or
conservative agenda items the idea of a
new Constitutional Convention also has
notable liberal supporters
in particular Sanford Levinson who
teaches at the University of Texas law
school and is one of the great
constitutional Scholars of his
generation has long been advocating for
a new convention
how would a constitutional convention
work
we haven't had a constitutional
convention since 1787 so it's hard to
say
however given the country's intense
political disagreements it seems safe to
assume that the process could be chaotic
and divisive especially since there are
no clear ground rules
for example there are no rules limiting
a constitutional convention to a single
topic so even if States called a
convention to propose say a balanced
budget amendment it's entirely possible
that the convention could propose
something else instead
it's also not clear whether Congress or
the states or even someone else would
get to select the delegates to a
convention
and if or how they could try to control
them
some commentators in fact point out that
the Constitutional Convention of 1787
was originally called only to modify the
Articles of Confederation
instead of tweaking the Articles the
framers did away with them entirely and
replaced them with something completely
different
there is therefore a precedent for rogue
delegates to a constitutional convention
going beyond their original mandate and
drafting a charter for a totally new
government
however a Constitutional Convention May
play out it is clear that it would be an
intensely political process
and while it might improve the existing
Constitution could also make things
worse to be sure a constitutional
convention would invite much needed
discussion about the strengths and
weaknesses of our current constitutional
order
but we should also be very cautious
before throwing it away
for all its problems the United States
is comparatively very prosperous and
stable
our constitution is also the world's
oldest written Constitution still in use
today
that longevity serves us well because it
helps ensure that people respect the
document
Americans accept the constraints the
Constitution imposes on their leaders
and the rights the Constitution grants
were the document to change dramatically
people might view the new version
differently and commitment to the rule
of law might suffer
in particular a convention's losers
might deem the end result illegitimate
if they thought that folks on the other
side had gained the process in their own
favor
so is constitutional law just politics
by another name
I wouldn't go that far but I do think
that constitutional law and politics are
inseparable
this is not to say that there is no such
thing as constitutional law or that
constitutional interpretation is just
thinly veiled political policy making
there is constitutional law
it exists in the text of the document
such as the requirement that the
president be at least 35 years old
it exists in the decisions of the U.S
Supreme Court which comprise precedent
that is binding on Lower federal courts
and state courts
and it exists in the practices of
governmental officials who take an oath
to abide by the Constitution and usually
believe themselves to be the
Constitution's faithful stewards
these elements however cannot be
understood in a political vacuum
the Constitution helps Define how
American politics operate
and these politics in turn shape the
content of our constitutional law such
as through the judicial confirmation
process
you cannot understand constitutional Law
Without some political insights but you
also can't understand U.S politics
without understanding the Constitution
it's partially for this reason that as
the nation has changed over time so too
is the Constitution
through formal Article 5 Amendment
through change judicial interpretations
and through change governmental and
societal practices
the Constitution is far from perfect and
as the framers recognized it never was
there's much to criticize about the
constitution of 1787. most obviously its
despicable pro-slavery provisions
but there is also something to admire
about many framers willingness to
compromise their ideals so that they
could create a new governmental order
that was a big Improvement on what had
come before it
at various points in our history the
country has lost this ability to
compromise including in its debates
about the meaning of the Constitution
as we continue to debate how to meet the
challenges of today and tomorrow
I hope that we like the founders will
try to listen to each other's views
about how to build a more perfect union